terme conduire et je me permets de vous
donner un petit flyer concernant le
fameux 80 km heure cet après-midi-là pas
d'amendés de perdre de points les
contrevenants sont sensibilisés les
gendarmes de la sécurité routière
contrôle sur la d 91 proche de la route
des dix sept tournant je suis très
agrément surpris qu aujourd'hui la
gendarmerie la police fasse de la
prévention et je trouvais que ça avait
disparu ces derniers temps donc voilà
c'est très positif je pense et on est
plus sensible à partir du moment c'est
de la prévention pas de la répression de
faire de la prévention je trouve ça une
bonne chose par contre le 80 je suis
vraiment pas pour sept militaires sont
mobilisés en deux équipes ils contrôlent
la vitesse et les flux en vallée de
chevreuse notre mission c'est de faire
appliquer le code de la route
llc mission assez simple mais il ya
plein de façons de le faire dans le cas
de cette mesure qui se fait en période
estivale à partir du dimanche
il est nécessaire d'accompagner cette
mesure donc des excès de vitesse qui
sont minimes qui sont mineurs si le
contrôle se passe de manière positive
avec la personne qui sont en infraction
on peut engager un dialogue et une
discussion pédagogique mardi 4 juillet
la nouvelle limitation est en place la
sensibilisation continue même hangar il
faut laisser le temps de voir quels
seront les effets est-ce qu'on parlait
tout lui dire non ça sert à rien si on
regarde bien ce qui a fait la prévention
routière depuis le début elle a imposé
le port du casque on a dit que ça
servait à rien imposer la ceinture de
sécurité à l'avant on a dit ça servent à
rien la ceinture de sécurité à l'arrière
on a dit que ça servait à rien cette
phase a eu un impact quand même sur
l'ombre 2003 près de contrôle indique
que c'est bon défi ça va fonctionner
correctement et là en fait la barre du
souk nous indique que fait positif a
qu'à la mise
c'est bien c'est au lieu de les voir
tout le temps faire des infractions il
nous explique un petit peu c'est je
pense que c'est c'est l'ordre des choses
avant de me venaient d'une infraction
nous expliquer comment ça fonctionne le
gouvernement espère sauver 400 vies par
an avec cette mesure dans les yvelines
58 radars sont présents deux sont
concernés par la mesure du 80 km heure